so i wanted to get your take on
inflation we're currently seeing i
recently had paul krugman on and he said
the fed should raise interest rates
effectively taking its foot off the gas
pedal and maybe pumping the brakes a
little bit but he said otherwise
inflation isn't a big deal as everyone
is making it out now you don't seem to
agree right that's wrong i mean first
look
the federal reserve is a very difficult
job because as i say that is the
stimulative
you give a lot of money and you give a
lot of buying power to people and you
create a pickup and that's what we did
they kept it on for a very long time and
they massively um stimulated
and now they're going to have to put on
the brakes
will they raise interest rates to a high
enough level to compensate for inflation
and when central banks tighten they
create the pinch and i think that
everybody knows you could see what
happens to tech stocks you can see what
happens so you were saying this might
cause a recession is that what you're
saying right that that trade-off
between inflation and growth
has produced a lot more inflation and a
lot less growth so as the federal
reserve tries to balance that and try to
get in the middle it gets a stag
flashing in the middle of two uh
difficult situations so how do you think
you use the word stagnation one of my
favorite words how do you think the
current economic environment fear of
stagflation and the actual occurrence of
stagflation will play out in the midterm
elections
i think it's a very big issue um and
it will play out in
hurting the democrats because they'll be
perceived as being responsible for it
and uh it'll be slogans and you know
there's going to be very little
understanding of the trade-offs and the
mechanics so we will have gone from
complaining about the depression that
existed as a result of covid to
complaining about the inflation but
they're not realizing that the two
things go together because the way you
give a lot of money away and you
minimize the the first problem but you
get the second